I briefly mentioned yesterday that
Donald Trump jr. the son of Donald Trump
was questioned behind closed doors about
all things Russia by the House
Intelligence Committee and I happen to
think and I've said before that the
House Intelligence Committee is not
likely to be the place that really makes
progress on figuring out what did and
didn't happen with Trump Russia but hey
they're still doing the investigation
I'll pay attention to what took place in
this committee hearing and one question
that we've all had and that the House
Intelligence Committee tried to explore
yesterday with Donald Trump jr. was how
much did Donald Trump himself know about
Russian contacts specifically and
including that infamous June 9th meeting
in Trump Tower wid the Russian lawyer
related to dirt on Hillary and the
easing of Russian sanctions do we know
that Donald Trump jr. was there we know
that Paul Manafort was there we know
that Jared Kushner was there and there
are others that were in the meeting that
we've outlined but Donald Trump
personally wasn't there
the timing of Trump's schedule for that
day and the timing of Donald Trump's
tweets that day suggests that he was
definitely in Trump Tower when the
meeting took place and that he was very
much aware of what took place because he
started tweeting just a couple hours
after the meeting about dirt on Hillary
and upcoming email releases so cut to
yesterday understandably members of the
House Intelligence Committee want to
know more about this but Donald Trump
jr. refused to answer and according to
congressman Adam Schiff who's on that
committee he's the ranking member Donald
Trump jr. did admit that he discussed
the meeting and the emails that led up
to the meeting with Donald Trump but he
refused to say anything else and here's
where it gets insane okay Donald Trump
jr. cited attorney-client privilege as
the reason why he was refusing to answer
the question but a prerequisite for
citing attorney-client privilege is that
someone in the conversation be an
attorney and and there is no such thing
as attorney-client privilege when Donald
Trump jr. is talking to Donald Trump
because neither of them are lawyers the
argument then became well listen during
the phone calls between Trump and Trump
jr. about this they both had their
attorneys present in the room
which is not how attorney-client
privilege works since this has to do
with communication between Trump and
Trump jr. an attorney-client privilege
involves communication with the attorney
now he could refuse to answer things
that he told his lawyer based on
attorney-client privilege but that's not
what he's refusing to answer he's
refusing to answer conversations between
about conversations between himself and
Donald Trump how stupid does Donald
Trump jr. think everybody is he's acting
like anything that takes place within 25
feet of a lawyer you never have to talk
about because of attorney-client
privilege and these are the details that
Donald Trump jr. is withholding that
could actually be really big in figuring
out how involved was Donald Trump how
knowledgeable how complicit and what's
horrible is that all lawyers agree that
this is BS doesn't seem that there's
gonna be any consequences for Donald
Trump jr. though he cited bogus ly
attorney-client privilege he's not a
lawyer the other person in the
conversation isn't a lawyer and yet it
appears like he's just gonna get away
with it yeah I mean if only these
testimonies weren't behind closed doors
I'd love to see this on TV
yeah public setting and to see this all
get challenged because this is a lame
excuse and everyone knows and as a
result of the fact that it was behind
closed doors it sort of becomes he said
she said he said whatever because Adam
Schiff came out ranking member ranking
Democrat on that committee and said yeah
he he cited attorney-client privilege is
the reason not to answer which is insane
because he's not a lawyer and neither is
Trump but then another Republican I
don't even remember who came out of the
meeting and said yeah Oh Donald Trump
jr. he answered all of our questions
super or forthcoming and he told us
everything we wanted to know yeah I
don't think so
and the attorney-client privilege I
almost am wondering if he thought he was
citing executive privilege even though
of course he doesn't actually have that
relationship with the President of the
United States anyway well nor was the
cuz he doesn't have an official position
but he doesn't have the same name as the
president though maybe he thought he was
the president maybe okay well he has
that and but that's the most sensible
reason why he wouldn't disclose this
that he shares a name with the President
of the United States that makes like
slightly more sense than attorney-client
village or even executive privilege
which isn't even what he asserted very
very weird and even more disgusting that
he was allowed to get away with it
today's program sponsored in part by
wink if I said I want you to pick out a
wine that you will definitely like but I
said it has to be a wine that you've
never tried before could you do it I
definitely couldn't because I'm clueless
about wine which brings in wink spelled
WI and C which makes it easy for you to
discover great wines each month they
ship you wines that are matched to your
tastes and personalized to you these are
wines you will love and they are shipped
right to your door you just open them
and enjoy them and you can go on to try
wink calm slash Pakman they have the
palate profile quiz they ask really
simple questions like how do you like
your coffee
do you like raspberries or blueberries
and then you get great wines in the mail
personalized to you delivered right to
your door you drink the wine then you
rate the wine and then the
recommendations become even more
tailored to your likes and dislikes
never any membership fees skip any month
cancel anytime 100% satisfaction
guarantee so you never pay for a bottle
you don't like and for a limited time
get $20 off when you go to try wink comm
slash Pakman that's t ry wi n c comm
slash PA k ma n for $20 off